in this video you're going to learn how
to find the surface area and the volume
of three-dimensional figures we're going
to talk about cones we're going to talk
about pyramids we're going to talk about
prisms and cylinders and spheres so
let's get into this video and we're go
through the formulas I'm going to show
you an easy way to remember these
formulas and how to group them together
so that you don't forget them and you'll
be able to solve these problems easily
so let's get into the first group of
problems the first group we're talking
about prisms okay and basically what a
prism is a prism is a figure a
three-dimensional figure where the two
bases are parallel okay and they're
congruent so that means they're the same
size and shape and they're parallel they
don't cross okay if they were to
continue to go and they're separated by
the height okay now I group cylinders
okay with these prisms because the
cylinder is really like a circular prism
you can see the two bases are circled
and they're separated by that height so
when you think about cylinders and
prisms think of them all as one group so
we're gonna do the surface area in the
volume so first of all let's do the
volume of this figure
now when you do the volume of the
formula the general formula is very easy
to remember it's the area of the base
times the height so that's why I did a
capital B so the area of the base means
you find the area of the bottom that's
what it sits on and you multiply it by
the height so essentially what this is
like it's like taking the area of this
square in this case okay which is 16
inches squared and it's like taking
those squares like a stack of sticky
notes and you stack them up okay 10
inches high so you take the area of the
base which is 16 times the height which
is 10 which is going to give us 160
inches cubed now the reason it's cubed
is because you know we're filling these
up with like little ice cubes you could
think of okay something like like that
right so a little 1 by 1 by 1 cubes and
that's how many are gonna fill up the
inside of this box right now let's talk
about the surface area for a moment so
the surface area is like if you were
going to take a paintbrush and you were
gonna paint all the sides you know of
this figure so when we think of the
surface area this is the formula that
you want to memorize it's to be okay the
capital B means the area of the base two
of them because you have a top and a
bottom plus the perimeter of the base
time's the height now let me see if I
can show you a three-dimensional figure
to help you to kind of understand this
better so what I have here okay with us
is basically a square prism okay so you
can see that there's a square there at
the top there's a square at the bottom
okay so if we take the area of this
square plus the area of this square that
takes care of the two bases but now if
you can kind of see here see the
perimeter of this square okay so you're
following me so if you take that
perimeter if you unfold this figure
that's the perimeter of that base okay
so remember this was folded up like so
okay but when we unfold it that's the
perimeter of our base times the height
and when you take the length times the
width or the base times the height
you're getting the area of this
rectangle okay so you're with me so far
so if I was to draw a net
okay net is like if you were to unfold
the shape what you would get is
something that looks like this you would
get four rectangles and you would have a
square here and a square here it's like
taking a shoebox and unfolding it you
might want to try that and so basically
this dimension right here is the
perimeter of the base this dimension
here is the height and that's where we
get the P times each that's what gives
us the lateral area or the area of the
sides then you just add the two bases
the top and bottom okay so let's do this
so basically the perimeter is going to
be 4 plus 4 plus 4 plus 4 which is 16
times the height which is 10 okay so on
my little diagram here this would be 10
and this would be 16 right so that's 160
okay plus the two bases and now the base
is a square so that's 4 times 4 is 16
times 2 since we have two of them so we
have 32 plus 160 which is 192 inches
squared okay now when you do area it's
square units because you're covering
this surface with these little 1 by 1
squares okay and that's how many would
cover the entire outer surface okay so
with me so far
so now let's go over to this shape here
I try this one on your own if you can
and basically what we do is do the same
thing this is a triangular prism in the
top and bottom our triangles they're
separated by that height which you can
see is 12 so let's start with the volume
first the volume is the area of the base
times the height okay now because this
is a triangle what you want to do is you
want to think of the ear
a formula for a triangle that's 1/2
little B times H so this is like our
base here 3 this is like our height of
our triangle here 4 so this is going to
be 1/2 times 3 times 4 and then our
height is going to be 12 ok so you don't
want to get the heights confused this H
is for the overall height the distance
between the two triangles this H is
really for the height of our triangle ok
so that's why I recommend just
memorizing the general formula then you
can break it down into the sub formulas
for each individual problem so let's go
ahead and simplify this so this comes
out to let's see 3 times 4 is 12 times
12 is 144 and half of that is 72 and I
didn't put the unit's here so I'm just
gonna say units cubed for the volume all
right now let's go over to the surface
area so surface area is really the total
outer area right so what we're gonna do
is we're use the same formula we were
talking about here earlier okay which is
the to be plus pH so 2 bases plus the
perimeter of the base times the height
so in this case what the base is going
to be a triangle so that's going to be 2
times 1/2 base times height plus the
perimeter of the base times the overall
height so let's see if we can do this so
basically 2 times 1/2 that's 1 so I'm
just going to cancel those out the base
of the triangle is 3 and the height of
the triangle is 4 the perimeter of the
base you have to add all these up 3 plus
4 plus 5 which gives us 12 and the
overall height is 12 so we get 144 plus
12 which is a hundred and fifty-six
units squared because this is area so
we're just covering this with these
little squares now if you want to see a
net okay like an unfolded picture of
this diagram let me see if I can put
that here for us it would look something
like this okay you would have 3 4 & 5
okay so when you unfold this and then
you would have a triangle over here like
this and a triangle over here like this
so if when you fold those that's going
to be the top and the bottom so that's
where we're getting this 12 that's the
perimeter okay times the height which is
this height here that's 12 so that's how
I'm getting 12 times 12 which gives you
this area
a hundred and forty-four then you just
have to add the two bases the two
triangles to get the total area okay one
more now we're going to talk about
cylinders again a cylinder is like a
circular prism you have the top and
bottom are circles they're separated by
that height so let's start with the
volume so the volume is the area of the
base times the height right so notice
I'm using the same formula for all these
prisms cylinders we're treating them as
a group okay so the area of the base
it's a circle so I'm going to write the
sub formula for the base which is PI R
squared times the height so in this case
the radius of the circle is 3 so that's
gonna be 3 squared the overall height is
6 so if we do this this is 3 squared is
9 times 6 is 54 pi you can put PI in
your calculator 3.14 and multiply these
together but I'm just gonna leave it as
54 pi meters cubed and again that's how
many little ice cubes that you know are
one meter by one meter by one meter that
would fill this gigantic cylinder now if
you want to do the surface area okay
what we're gonna do is we're going to
again think of this as a net so if we
unfold this like I always take some
scissors and cut that right there and
unfold it you're gonna have a circle
here a circle here and you're gonna have
a rectangle here when you roll that
rectangle nice if I can show you a piece
of paper here it's gonna look like this
right so there's the circle at the top
there's a circle at the bottom but when
I enroll this there is our rectangle
right there now when you look at this
dimension here
okay this dimension is really the
circumference of the circle right so
when I enroll that this is the
circumference that's just another name
for the perimeter okay of the base so
we're gonna use our formula to be plus
pH but remember the perimeter is really
this dimension okay that's like
unrolling this circle here like this so
this is going to give us two PI R this
is our height so that's where we get our
perimeter two PI R times the overall
height plus two bases remember the base
is a circle so PI R squared so now all
we have to do is substitute in the
values so we've got two pi the radius is
three squared plus two pi the radius is
three and the height is six and we just
have to simplify so this would be 9
times 2 is
18 pi this is 18 times 2 is 36 PI if we
add those together we get 54 pi meters
squared and it's just a coincidence that
these both came out to 54 pi this is
meters squared this is how many square
meters would cover the outer surface of
this cylinder so again think about
volume and surface area you know just
these three basic formulas B times H the
area of the base times the height and
then the surface area formula to be plus
pH to find the outer area okay next
we're going to talk about pyramids and
cones let me erase this board and we'll
start with those okay now we're going to
talk about pyramids and cones and you
want to group pyramids and cones
together just to help you to narrow down
the number of formulas you have to
memorize and just make it easier overall
so a pyramid in a cone
you'll notice they both just have one
base so they just have the one bottom
unlike prisms that had a top and the
bottom that were parallel and congruent
you just have one base and you can see
they go up to a point here okay this one
vertex point at the top now when you
look at a pyramid in a cone they've got
two different things going on they've
got this overall height okay which goes
right down to the center of the base see
this 12 right here and then they have
something called a slant height or which
they use the letter L for which I kind
of call it the leaning height because
it's at an angle like that so that's the
slant height right there are 13 and in
this case the slant height is 5 so we're
going to talk about those in these
problems but first let's do the volume
so the volume we're going to use this
formula here one-third the area of the
base times the height okay so what you
do is you take the area of this bottom
piece which is 6 times 6 that's 36 times
1/3 times the height now the height that
you want to use is this overall height
straight down to the center of the base
in that case this one's 4 so this comes
out to let's see 48 inches cubed since
it's volume all right so you with me so
far
what this means this one-third area the
base times the height remember when we
did the prisms okay like if I was to
draw a prism like say for example like
this okay just a rough sketch here what
you can see is if these had the same
base and they had the same height if you
put this pyramid inside
this prism you would actually be able to
fit three of these inside of there okay
so this one plus two more because you
can see it's tapered it's you know angle
up to a point like so so this actually
only takes up a third of this volume so
that's where this 1/3 is coming into
play now let's go over to this one let's
talk about the cone now so same formula
a volume is 1/3 area the base times the
height in this case the base is a circle
so we're going to use the formula PI R
squared for a circle ok area of a circle
times the height and again we want to
use this overall height straight down to
the center of the base that's 12 and
let's see so for the circle the radius
is 5 so that's going to be 5 squared is
25 okay now just a note here to you and
that's that you know when you're
multiplying these together
multiplication is commutative you can
change the order you're gonna get the
same result right so I'm going to take
1/3 of 12 which is 4 times 25 is 100
times pi so this is going to be 100 PI
units cubed and that's it you got the
volume now let's talk about the surface
area so the surface area the formula
we're going to use for both the pyramid
and the cone is area of the base since
you just have one bottom okay plus 1/2
the perimeter of the base times the
slant height okay that's the same
formula over here or volume is an area
of the base plus one half the perimeter
times the slant height but what's
different is it's a different shape
bassy this is a square so 6 times 6 is
36 right this one over here is a circle
so that's going to be PI R squared so pi
times 5 squared okay over here we're
going to take the perimeter which is 6
plus 6 plus 6 plus 6 4 6 is just 24 and
the slant height of the leaning height
which is 5 right but over here what we
have is we have a circle so we have to
take the perimeter of a circle which is
the circumference which remember the
formula for circumference is 2 PI R so 2
pi times 5 times the slant height so
that leaning height which is 13 so I
think of that al I think of the leaning
height right now all we have to do is go
back and simplify so we've got 1/2 of 24
to 12 12 times 5 is 60 and we just add
the 36 and the 60 together to get 96
inches squared so remember square for
area that's 2 dimensional cube for
it's three-dimensional for this one we
get five squared is 25 pi let's see two
times five is ten times 1/2 is five
that's five pi times 13 is 65 pi right
and if we add those together what do we
get we get 8090 pi units squared now
notice I just left the PI in there
that's an exact answer but if you want
to get an approximation you can put 3.14
four pi multiplied by 90 and you got it
so again for pyramids and columns you
want to think of the two basic formulas
which is the volume formula see it's the
same 1/3 area of the base times the
height and for the surface area I wrote
volume here this is surface area okay
the outer surface okay one base plus
one-half PL so it's just the area of the
one bottom plus one half the perimeter
times the slant height so let me erase
this board and then we're going to talk
about spheres but the key is to group
these together to make it easier you
know to memorize these formulas okay
lastly we're going to talk about spheres
but before I get into spheres I just
wanted to mention that if you're
preparing for the AC T or the SAT Math
section and you want to boost your score
I've got two courses available you can
check them out I've got links on my
about page I'll put links in the
description below but basically I've got
one for the SAT which goes over 39
concept areas that are important to
really you know boost your score on the
test and then with the a CT math section
I've got 65 concepts they're really
going to depth with teaching and
examples and practice problems and so
forth to really help you to boost your
score so if you like my teaching style
check out those courses a lot of
students have benefited from them and
I'm sure you will too but let's talk
about spheres now so a sphere is
basically like a circle in three
dimensions you know it's the set of all
points that are equidistant from a given
point which is called the center so it's
basically like a ball like a basketball
right and so if we're trying to find the
volume like the inner space the
three-dimensional space we're going to
be using this formula here it's 4/3 pi
times the radius cubed so they're really
just that one dimension the radius now
sometimes I'll try to confuse you a
little bit me by giving you the diameter
but you can always cut it in half too
the radius so for this one we're just
gonna say 4/3 PI times 3 cubed 3 cubed
is 3 times 3 times 3 which is 27 so we
have 4/3 times pi times 27 which is like
27 over 1 and you can do a little bit of
cross reducing numerator and denominator
here so that ends up coming out to
multiply the numerators and dynamic to
gather that gives you 36 PI units cube
that's the volume right now for the
surface area the form is a little bit
different it's 4 PI R squared okay and
what we want to do here is just put in
our radius which is 3 so that's 3
squared is 9 times 4 is 36 PI units
squared since its area that's the outer
surface now it's just a coincidence we
came out with 36 for both of these but
the formula is different you won't
always get that that situation so again
just trying to show you an easy way to
group these together memorize the
general formula then you can break it
down for each specific shape whether
it's a triangular pyramid or it's a
square pyramid or it's a cone or
whatever type of shape it is so I hope
you enjoyed this video subscribe to the
channel check out over the over 400
other videos I have on my Morrow's math
tutor YouTube channel to help you boost
your score in your math class improve
your understanding and make math
learning math a lot less stressful and I
look forward to seeing the future videos
I'll talk to you soon